this video is brought to you by
squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
squarespaces the all-in-one platform to
build a beautiful online presence and
run your business check out squarespace
through the link in the description
below more about them in a bit
mad
bad
and dangerous to know with these words
lady caroline lamb carved out a literary
epitaph that would last centuries
written in reference to lord byron they
sum up everything that still appeals
about the brooding libertine poet george
gordon byron was young charismatic
talented at the age of just 24 he
published one of the biggest hits in the
whole of english poetry becoming famous
overnight he was daring traveling the
mediterranean becoming embroiled in
secret societies and joining revolutions
he was also handsome and sexually
adventurous in england he shocked high
society with his affairs with married
women while on the continent he found
comfort in the embrace of beautiful
young men he was in short the archetype
of a romantic poet a decadent bohemian
aristocrat living a scandalous life even
as he produced some of the greatest
poems that the world has ever known yet
there was more to lord byron than this
simple portrait would suggest beneath
the dashing exterior lurked a soul riven
by insecurity plagued with body image
problems and capable of treating his
family in the most appalling way
imaginable awful and wonderful both hero
and villain this is the life of lord
byron literature's original bad boy
for nearly all his adult life lord byron
was gripped with an unhealthy fear that
he would one day go mad rather than the
affected pose of a laosh aristocrat this
worry was very real the fear that came
from deep within the poet's heart after
all with the parents he had had it's
perhaps a wonder that he had any sanity
at all born gordon george byron on the
22nd january 1788 the future poet was
the product of a match maid somewhere in
the ninth circle of hell his father was
a dissolute drunk known as mad jack who
gambled all of his wife's money away
before fleeing abroad while she was
pregnant as a result byron's mother gave
birth to him completely alone in a
rented room driven near bankruptcy by
the man she married not that katherine
gordon was exactly a model parent
herself moody aggressive and capable of
staggering cruelty the boy's mother
would swing between smothering him with
love and belittling his disability byron
had been born with a withered right leg
that caused constant pain and left him
horribly self-conscious but rather than
accept her boy for who he was his mother
used this self-consciousness as a weapon
in her darker mood catherine would zero
in on the boy's leg calling him lame
brat or her limping devil while her
casual cruelty would give her son
lifelong hang-ups as an adult he'd wear
special boots designed to hide his
disability they also turned him into
someone capable of matching his mother's
put-downs seizing upon her weight the
child byron would scream back that she
was as fat as a sow he began blaming her
for his condition chalking his painful
leg up to catherine's insistence on
wearing a corset while pregnant all in
all then it was a miserable life the
pair lived shut off from the world in
gentile poverty swinging between toxic
arguments and painful codependency
incredibly this wasn't even the worst of
it in 1791 when byron was only three mad
jek died in france his last act was to
pass all of his debts onto his young son
mad jagbeyer and everybody her dad so
deadbeat was still talking about how
crappy he was
230 years later despite his father's
feelings though byron would always
consider him a free spirited adventurer
but then given how awful his home life
was perhaps his young brain simply
needed the escapism in 1797 catherine
hired a strict calvinist named mary gray
as her son's nurse sadly gray was one of
those christians who used religion not
as a way to reflect and better
themselves but rather as a way to
browbeat others violent and drunken she
liked to hit the boy telling him how
sinful and wretched he was far worse
than the physical abuse though was the
sexual abuse when the boy was either
nine or ten the age varies in different
versions mary gray began grooming him
culminating in a sustained sexual
assault in her bed it took two years for
the boy to block up the courage to tell
anyone but even then there was no great
reckoning gray was dismissed from the
family's employ and simply vanished from
the pages of history yet the hurt she
caused didn't vanish with her in his
later life lord byron would become as
we'll soon see capable of breathtaking
acts of cruelty towards his lovers
especially when they were female as bad
as his behavior becomes though just bear
in mind this dreadful childhood growing
up in a household filled with both
mental and sexual abuse its remarkable
byron didn't turn out any worse than he
actually did
[Music]
it was the 21st of may 1798 when the
family's fortunes suddenly turned that
day byron's great uncle the guy so
villain as he was simply called the
wicked lord died having outlived all his
heirs with no one else to take it byron
got his great uncle's aristocratic title
more gratifying though was the second
part of his inheritance newstead abbey a
gossip pile badly in need of repair
newstead was the archetypal great
country home young byron fell in love
with the place enchanted by its vast
corridors and crumbling walls sure he
had to rent a doubt to a 23 year old
baron to pay off the family's debt but
it was still a step up there were other
positive changes happening around this
time too shortly after inheriting
newstead byron met his cousin margaret
parker for the first time beautiful and
enchanting she knocked young byron off
his feet it was thanks to this meeting
that the boy sat down and wrote his
first piece of poetry but these twin
beams of sunshine were just a quick
respite from the endless black skies of
byron's early life in 1801 the boy was
sent to study at harrow an elite
boarding school that was also a hotbed
of bullying the other boy seized on
byron's disability torturing him over
his withered leg and his weight yup his
weight as he got older byron had fleshed
out but rather than accept this the
accumulating fat instilled in him an
eating disorder he began eating
starvation amounts of food fighting off
his hunger with tobacco until his death
he'd yo-yo in weight between freakishly
thin and noticeably obese nor was food
the only hangout that byron was
developing some biographers have
suggested that byram was seduced around
this time by the baron renting newstead
an experience that seems to have left
him angry and confused yet if byron was
messed up after his first homosexual
encounter the feeling wouldn't last by
the time he entered cambridge in 1805
byron was already aware that he had
romantic feelings for both men and women
it was at university that he met his
first love a choir boy two years his
junior called john edelston according to
byron he loved the boy with a violent
though pure love and passion with many
scholars taking the pure part to mean
his attraction was unrequited certainly
this would fit the later pattern in the
poet's life of falling for beautiful
straight boys that he couldn't have this
wasn't like lusting after a straight
friend today homosexuality in early 19th
century england wasn't just illegal but
it was punishable by death when byron
wrote love poetry about edelston he was
forced to invent a female name to hide
the truth still it wouldn't be love
poetry whether directed at men or at
women that would make byron's name but a
literary cat fight come 1806 baron had
run out of cash abandoning cambridge for
london he borrowed money from his
estranged half-sister augusta to make
ends meet while there he began compiling
his early poems finally publishing them
in 1807 as hours of idleness sadly a
better title might have been great big
piles of poo the press were merciless
with the 21 year old's verse the
edinburgh review gleefully took a
hatchet to the book portraying bayern
and some talentless hack who didn't know
his villanelle from his ass it was a
nightmare review the sort of write-up
that would put most off writing for life
instead the review wound up being
byron's making rather than abandon
poetry the poet went on the attack over
the winter of 1808 to 1809 byron
composed what was basically a diss track
so epic it makes ice cubes no vaseline
look like something by vanilla ice known
as english bards and scotch reviewers
the poem attacked not just the edinburgh
review but also pretty much every major
poet in england it was poisonous angry
impertinent it was also brilliant
suddenly lord byron could no longer be
dismissed to some rich idiot the
snarling cynical genius of infamy had
arrived now just before we continue with
today's video let me tell you about our
fantastic sponsor squarespace two simple
things maybe you've got an idea for a
website or a business or a youtube
channel or a podcast something like that
knocking around in your mind well two
the only way to find out whether that's
worth doing is to get it out into the
world and that can be daunting because
it's always scary to go and pursue new
things but not knowing how to set up a
website is no excuse there are no
excuses available with squarespace
squarespace allows you to create a
powerful website for whatever you want
to do sell something online yes set up a
store with squarespace you want to do a
podcast to start a youtube channel well
i mean you'll do the youtube channel on
youtube but you'll want a website to
complement it and if you've got a
podcast well yes put it on squarespace
it all starts on squarespace with a
beautiful template that you can
customize to your heart's content or you
can start from scratch or just move over
from an existing domain making
everything super easy to manage and once
you've gone through the customization
process there's no updates there's no
patches there's no technical nonsense to
deal with and squarespace also handles
all that websitey stuff podcasts like i
said but also mailiness social
integrations member areas and so much
more head to squarespace.com for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch go
to squarespace.com forward slash
biographics to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or a domain
and back to today's video
the summer of 1809 saw byron and his
friend john hop house depart england for
a grand tour around the mediterranean in
itself this wasn't unusual the grand
tour was simply part of a wealthy
englishman's upbringing in this era what
was unusual though was byron's main
motivation from his letters at the time
it's clear that he mostly wanted a
guilt-free way to seduce a metric heck
ton of boys across greece and albania
the young lord fell in and out of love
with countless dashing young men
reveling in how open the mediterranean
societies were about homosexuality in
england he wrote with evident delight
the vices in fashion are whoring and
drinking in turkey sodomy and smoking
but while this turkish style was perfect
for an attractive young bisexual guy
byron wasn't just thinking with his dick
he could also see around him the greeks
and albanians chafing under the rule of
the decaying ottoman empire their desire
for liberation preyed on his mind and
that in case you somehow missed it is
what we call foreshadowing still
oppressed greeks or no oppressed greeks
byron's thoughts at this time were
mostly occupied with his writing the
critical success of english bards had
triggered a creative hot streak as he
and hobhouse traveled to places like
malta portugal and spain that creative
energy began to get focused on a big
project one that would apply byron's
developing cynical style to places that
it visited child harold's pilgrimage was
a work that would become a pillar of
european romanticism following a
world-weary narrator on his
mediterranean travels it was moody
contemplative decadent and utterly ahead
of its time in fact it was so cutting
edge that byron initially refused to
publish it thinking it would cause a
scandal it was only thanks to tragedy
that the perm ever saw the light of day
in 1811 byron returned to england to be
informed that his mother was gravely ill
although he raced from london to
newstead he was too late by the time he
arrived catherine gordon was dead
despite their difficult relationship his
mother's death nearly broke byron at
first he went into isolation when that
didn't help his mood he went on a
violent spree of seduction forcing
himself on the abbey serving girls
desperate to pull himself back from the
brink his friends pushed him into
working on child harold the purr
grumbled then agreed then threw himself
into the writing it was a decision that
would change everything the release of
child harald's first two kantos in march
1812 was perhaps the biggest literary
event of the regency era remember when
gangnam star took over the entire planet
back in 2012 with a speed that would
never seen before well that was child
harold two centuries earlier albeit with
less funky dancing the prince run sold
out in three days as barron himself
later said i awoke one morning and found
myself famous what followed was an era
of byron mania suddenly every club in
london wanted him as a member society
hostesses were begging him to entertain
at their parties it helped that the
poem's narrator was clearly modeled on
byron rather than just another writer
those who invited him were getting
something far more interesting a
character and byron was nothing if not a
character with his studied good looks
quick tongue and hint of the devil byron
was for the regency what oscar wilde
would be for the late victorian era
after the long pious slog of george the
third's reign britain was changing in
byron had finally found a poet who
embodied that change he is really the
only topic almost of every conversation
the duchess of devonshire wrote the men
jealous of him the women of each other
indeed society women were mad for byron
they wrote him by the hundreds begging
for a lock of his hair but they were too
late by the spring of 1812 byron only
had eyes for one person lady carolyn
lamb unfortunately this new obsession
would wind up a disaster for both of
them
in later life byron would recall the
years 1812 to 1815 as his reign when he
was in his prime and adored across
london but you could just as easily call
them the years of dangerous
relationships in quick succession byron
was to get involved with three women one
it destroy another he'd be destroyed by
and the third would be an exercise in
mutual destruction it was into this
latter category that lady caron and lamb
fell slender androgynous and unable to
give the tiniest crap what society
thought of her lamb should have been the
perfect match for byron for a few months
she was the two had a wild and kinky
affair with bayern encouraging her to
cross-dress and engaging in scandalous
love-making with him it was lamb who
famously wrote the byron was mad bad and
dangerous to know yet in reality those
words were far better suited to her by
the fall of 1812 byron becomes so
freaked out by lam's erratic behavior
that he broke off their affair by a
letter the next time they bumped into
each other at a ball lamb smashed a
glass and started cutting her arms in
front of him a scene that destroyed her
social standing still for all byron may
have damaged her catherine lamb would at
least have her revenge the same can't be
said for the poet's next love annabelle
milbank was lamb's cousin a
down-to-earth mathematician who was a
far cry from wild child caroline she and
byron struck up her friendly
correspondence at first with few
romantic overtures as lamb snidely noted
byron would never be able to pull with a
woman who went to church punctually
understood statistics and had a bad
figure but at some point in 1813 things
changed byron wrote to anabella
suggesting marriage for reasons that are
still unknown one theory is that he
wanted a wife to deflect suspicion about
his ongoing gay affairs another is well
we'll come to that in a minute for now
we'll note that annabella turned byron
down only to have a change of heart in
1814 and tell him he could ask again
byron didn't hesitate the pair wed in
january 1815 and from the get-go it was
clear that this was a more cursed match
than even that of mad jack and katherine
gordon byron seemed to find alabella
loathsome in some undefined way the
night they married he was found
wandering about with a loaded pistol
muttering about blowing his brains out
he taunted his new wife with hints of
gay love affairs openly seduced an
actress while anabella was pregnant with
his child but the biggest issue of all
was also byron's third great love of
this period augusta the daughter of mad
jack augusta was byron's half-sister a
married respectable ish woman we briefly
introduced loaning him money two
chapters back when they reconnected in
1813 though the pair no longer wanted to
be just siblings they wanted to be
lovers now it's important to point out
that no definitive proof exists of byron
in augusta's incestual relationship that
being said there are so many red flags
that take it together they become a
giant semaphore signal screaming warning
this is gross this is the other theory
behind byron's ill-advised marriage that
he needed to throw people off the center
of his affair with his half-sister but
if that's the case it failed mainly
because byron himself kept dropping
hints to annabella about it by this time
their marriage was beyond repair byron
was being cruel to his heavily pregnant
wife smashing bottles and firing pistols
to keep her from getting to sleep at
night things finally culminated in
december of 1815. on the 10th annabella
gave birth to their daughter ada byron
better known to history as the
pioneering programmer ada lovelace no
way
how did i feel like i must know that
that's crazy
i feel like i did know that damn i mean
i must have made a video about it that's
crazy two days later while she was still
recovering byron allegedly entered the
room and sodomized her we say allegedly
because as with much of lord byron's
private life it's unknown what was
really true and what were just rumors
concocted by his enemies either way
annabella fled with their daughter just
a month later not long after rumors
began doing the rounds of domestic
violence and abuse within their marriage
yet it was the other rumors that would
annihilate byron's reputation aware the
winds were shifting against the poet
carolyn lam began spreading her own
stories about byron of incest of
homosexual lovers in no time at all
these tales would turn byron from the
darling of english society into a
desperate wounded exile
back when byron was on his grand tour a
proto-police force known as the bow
street runners had raided london's white
swan pub the target had been the gay man
who gathered there in the trials that
followed six were sentenced to the
stocks and another two were hanged their
official crime was sodomy and it
triggered a crackdown so violent that
not even someone as wealthy as byron
could escape it when the accusations of
incest homosexuality and sodomy broke
against him byron transformed overnight
into a walking target his friends feared
he'd be lynched in the streets so the
poet did the only thing he could he ran
on april 25 1816 lord byron boarded a
ship for the european mainland although
he traveled in style not just taking his
personal physician john polidori but
also a pet monkey and peacock there was
no getting over the sadness of the
occasion the departure of the boat from
dover marked the last time byron would
ever see his home country from a
literary perspective though this exile
was the best thing that could have ever
happened shunned by society byron now
began working harder than ever writing
with an anger that pushed his poems to
new heights it would be while on this
creative streak that he made his most
important artistic friendship back in
england one of byron's many lovers had
been 18 year old claire claremont when
she heard that he was going to spend
part of his exile in geneva she pushed
her stepsister mary wollstonecraft
godwin and mary's fiancee to travel
there with her and so it was that the
future mary shelly and her lover the
struggling romantic poet percy by she
shelley came to be in switzerland at the
perfect time to meet lord byron we say
perfect because the friendship the three
struck up transformed literary history
it was byron's suggestion that they all
tell ghost stories while reigned in one
night and that led to mary shelley write
in frankenstein as well as polidori
creating the modern vampire novel percy
shelly and byron meanwhile inspired one
another both saw a great outpouring of
work during their time together work
that would redefine english poetry sadly
things were nowhere near so positive for
claire claremont that summer in geneva
byron seduced her knocked her up and
then got bored of her and encouraged her
to return to england that claire gave
birth to their daughter clara allegra
byron it was the beginning
of a nightmare byron's treatment of
claire and allegra remains one of the
biggest black marks against him a
mixture of cruelty and callous
indifference that still stomach churning
to hear first he sent for allegra
telling claire that he could provide a
better life for her only to quickly get
bored of the child and pass her off onto
friends he then blocked claire from
having any contact with her refusing to
reply to her pitiful letters begging for
news he started referring to allegra as
that brat and claiming she wasn't his
before finally dumping her in convent
she died there at the age of five
unloved and only visited by percy
shelley on her deathbed she begged to
see her father and the poet never came
at the same time as his daughter was
enduring her short and miserable
childhood byron was settling into a new
life in italy and beginning work on his
masterpiece don juan is a satirical epic
drenched in sex and scandal both far
richer and far darker than anything
byron had yet attempted partially a
sustained send-up of multiple nations it
was both an enormous success back in
england and also so scandalous that his
publisher refused to put his name on it
but while don juan would go down in
history as his most lasting achievement
it wasn't a literature that byron would
dedicate what remained of his life but
to revolution
[Music]
by 1820 byron was getting restless while
writing epic poetry in an ancient city
whilst also having an affair with a
beautiful italian countess would
probably be enough excitement for most
of us byron felt something lacking he
thought about traveling to south america
then still fighting its wars of
independence or maybe returning to
england to lead a revolution in sure
byron was searching for something more
than just art for some meaningful
romantic cause to dedicate his life to
fortunately 1820s europe was awash with
romantic causes that year the secret
carbonari societies of italy began a
series of uprisings against austrian
rule that countess byron was seeing
countess teresa guccioli well her
brother was a member of the carbonari
through him byron joined italy's fight
for freedom and unification something he
called a grand object the very poetry of
politics sadly the uprisings were
quickly beaten back byron and the
countess's family fled romantic dreams
of revolution unfulfilled yet italian
unification wasn't the only great cause
going in early 1821 greece exploded in
revolt against his ottoman occupiers in
no time at all societies sympathetic to
the greek cause were flourishing across
europe in england the london greek
committee sprang up determined to help
one of its members happened to be
byron's old friend john hobhouse the
guide accompanied byron on his grand
tour all to aware of his pal's fondness
for greece hobau suggested they sound
the poet out about helping maybe
hobhouse was expecting money maybe just
support for their cause what he got was
a military commander when he heard the
proposal byron declared he'd sail for
greece immediately using ten thousand
pounds of his own money he paid to
improve the greek navy and fund a small
mercenary force that would operate under
his command on the vayner side he also
paid for an absurd greek costume to wear
and had himself painted in it looking
heroic but while byram was certainly a
poser he was also actually a guy who did
stuff in august 1823 he set sail for the
heart of the war yet despite his dreams
he'd never see action incapable of
knowing he was now in the last few
months of his life byron spent the rest
of the summer and all of autumn on the
island of catalonia making contacts for
the coming campaign he also fell in love
with the last time with a straight greek
chap called lucas challenger sanos who
politely refused the older man's amorous
advances it was only in early 1824 that
byron actually arrived in miss alongi to
join the forces of prince alexander
mavrocordatos at first it seemed to be
the beginning of something big byron as
the wealthy foreign celebrity who joined
their cause got a hugely enthusiastic
reception from the greeks the rest of
january was spent making military plans
for when the bad weather finally let up
in the end though byron would never see
any of these plans through in a poetic
world we'd now tell you that byron died
in battle enjoying the hero's death that
he so clearly craved but that's not the
world we live in in this world byron's
health nosedive that spring following a
convulsion although he tried to relax
and recover things only got worse until
on the rainy morning of april the 10th
1824 the poet was stricken with fever
his physicians tried draining his blood
a cure that made things worse before
long byron was delirious slipping in and
out of dreams in which he was spit about
augusta finally on april the 19th he was
heard to mutter i want to sleep now then
with those words he died the news of
byron's passing age just 36 spread
quickly across greece where it became a
rallying cry for battle it took far
longer to reach his homeland people in
london only heard the news about a month
later at which time the entire city
plunged into shock byron might have been
a scandalous even despised figure but he
was also a mega star one of those people
you can't imagine ever dying until they
actually do when his body was returned
from greece against his wishes crowds
lined the street to pay their last
respects to say goodbye to the poet who
defined an entire era with 200 years of
hindsight we can now see that byron's
legacy was even longer lasting than
anyone could have imagined today he's
likely the best-known english poet after
shakespeare his influence visible across
multiple generations characters like
heathcliff public icons like oscar wilde
even rock stars all owe a debt of
gratitude to byron's work and life of
course nowadays we're more likely to be
turned off by byron's dark side by his
treatment of loved ones and his many
casual cruelties even so there's no
denying that he remains a towering
figure a pioneer not just in literature
but in revolutionary politics lgbt
history and more the man may have died
but the romantic byronic myth
lives on so i really hope you found this
video interesting if you did please do
hit that thumbs up button below don't
forget to subscribe and as always
thank you for watching